well if you don't have a pool a popular
location to try and beat the heat this
week is going to be a community pool
but you need extra protection there as
well from these extreme temperatures
sally jaramillo stopped by the desert
breeze aquatic center with how they're
keeping swimmers safe
even though pools are open and you are
enjoying yourself it's always a good
reminder that you
pause the fun get out the sun and
hydrate
desert breeze recreation specialist
travis smith says
every year safety is their number one
priority and therefore reminds visitors
that even though the pool may feel very
nice and comfortable
drinking water is a necessity even when
you're not thirsty
so if you visit the pool you must have a
plan pack extra water
and snacks and especially take breaks
dehydration can occur with water loss
from sweating and in the long run
cause nausea vomiting and muscle cramps
even inside the pool
dehydration still affects you one thing
that people don't notice is when they're
in the water they don't feel themselves
sweating because they're wet everywhere
so it's really important to keep in mind
that
just because you don't feel that sweat
you are sweating while you're in the
pool
at desert breeze recreational center
smith says they have safety breaks every
two to three hours
where they ask everyone to get out of
the pool drink water put on sunscreen
and have a snack if they need it smith
says
live cars are still in high demand
currently
they are looking for certified ones
reporting sally jaramillo
8 news now another reminder if your
child is under eight you're
always required to stay by their side